Sophia is a year and a half old she's
lucky to be alive an estimated nine out
of ten women in Germany decide to have
abortions when they find out their
unborn child
has Down syndrome Anna tusen was seven
months pregnant when she got the
diagnosis of course I was scared I was
worried I was also feeling a bit
desperate I didn't know what to do I was
still in the last year of my studies but
I had a lot of support and courage and
because she was so active in my ballet
Sophia also showed me that she wanted to
live and she should be allowed to live
the weeks that followed were difficult
for Anna who was also working as a
geriatric nurse she read all about Down
syndrome which is a genetic disorder in
which children are almost always born
with physical and intellectual
disabilities the doctor told Anna her
child would be born with a heart defect
suddenly Anna faced the dilemma of
whether to have an abortion come all so
forth they immediately told me I could
have an abortion but I thought if I have
an abortion I'll have to give birth to a
stillborn child I didn't even want to
think about that nothing new Karolina
Hennig a gynecologist counsels women who
decide to have an abortion when they get
a diagnosis of Down syndrome she knows
the pressure for all involved there are
so many factors to consider how old am i
how stable is my relationship do my
other children still need a lot of
attention I like to tell my patients
that they just have to decide what's
easiest for them Hennig says the blood
test that detects Down syndrome as early
as 10 weeks of pregnancy gives families
time to make difficult decisions early
on that's also important to ensure that
mother and child are well looked after
if the mother decides to have her baby
for onna Tizen the issue goes deeper
she says the blood test sends a message
that society does not accept children
like Sophia I ask myself why and if you
then don't have to pay for the test
these children will simply not exist
even though they're perfectly happy
children who radiate joy and have so
much love to give
the blood tests for Down syndrome are
already a standard procedure in Denmark
and France in those countries few
children like Sophia are born I'm now
joined by Peter Brook he's the chair of
the German ethics Council which advises
the German government welcome at mr.
Dubrow you have spoken out in favor of
reimbursing the costs of genetic testing
why thank you first for having me I I
was not quite in favor of reimbursing
the tests but my statement was we do not
have sufficient reasons for not
reimbursing it if we at the very same
time reimburse the invasive tests and
that is the reason it is a question of
social justice why we then should also
reimburse this non-invasive test and for
people who are not aware mr. deverel can
you explain the difference between an
invasive and a non-invasive test in this
context yeah of course
we have first the amniocentesis which is
invasive and it has the risk of 1 to 3%
of failure in or sudden birth and the
blood test has not this adverse side
effect and therefore there are good
medical reasons for since they have the
very same results in terms of medicine
to also reimburse the a non-invasive
test but of course we have further
societal questions to tackle absolutely
because associations for people with
disabilities say that this sends a
signal that people with Down syndrome
are not wanted what do you say to them
that is a really serious question but I
think the one hand is the conflict on
the end of the parents the woman who is
pregnant and on the other hand the
societal effect Iceland does provide
such tests for free of charge and the
possibility of terminating a pregnancy
after a dance positive result as it
consequences almost no children with
Down syndrome are being born but some
German politicians have already voiced
concerns let's listen to what one Green
Party politician had to say desgas on
time system is that our health system is
meant to heal people this test cannot
heal Down syndrome because Down syndrome
is not a disease we can't heal it and
we're not supposed to so what's this all
about
this screening is designed and we should
be very clear about this to select
children without this condition okay so
what do you say to this what is your
response to this mr. Dabdoub
how should one deal with this risk of
selection I think this is a point mostly
seriously taking into account because on
the one hand I think we have to do
everything to improve a culture of
inclusiveness of all different forms of
human beings and human persons so
therefore I'm very much in line with all
and I had the impression it were were
nearly all parliamentarians who were in
favor of this attitude and I was
impressed by this very general approach
of the parliamentarians but on the other
hand we also have to take into account
that that that parents that mothers
are really struggling am I ready to
accept this well it is a more difficult
life and the best answer to this is not
to on the one hand reimbursed the
invasive tests or on the other hand not
the non-invasive tests but to do
everything to improve and support all
lives and relationships with people and
not only trisomy 21 people who do not
meet the expectations of the society
right it's a big ethical question Peter
Darach chair of the German ethics
Council which advises the German
government thank you very much for
sharing your thoughts with us on DW
thank you